[Aplausos]
sí bueno
escucha bien
si se escucha perfecto
mi nombre es gilberto castro-tirado como
lo mencionó a néstor actualmente tengo
31 años y me dedico a la producción
musical ya a estudiar la licenciatura en
música clásica en la jugada
revolución humana transformando el
veneno en remedio
antes de empezar con mi charla me
gustaría hacer un ejercicio con todos
ustedes pidiéndoles primero que nada que
se pongan de pie por favor
muchas gracias muchas gracias
ahora voy a compartirles cuatro palabras
que cambiaron radicalmente mi vida y
hasta la fecha son el impulso que le doy
a esta
vamos a repetir estilo freddie mercury
en wembley
vamos primero yo voy a decir una palabra
y ustedes la repiten vamos a empezar con
nam
muy bien
mi ojo
wenger
yo muy bien lo dijeron muy muy bien
ahora vamos a juntar las todas y va a
sonar algo como la mejor en gay o
la verdad muchas gracias puede soltarse
muy bien ahora que todos estamos
conectados al wifi de mi cerebro vamos a
empezar con mi charla bueno más bien voy
a empezar yo con mi charla lamió joven
gay yo es el título de sutra de loto una
enseñanza que que es el fondo y el piso
de la revolución humana
esta enseñanza de la mejor en getxo
llega a mi vida a los 19 años desde muy
pequeño y se re dando el amor por la
humanidad y el servicio de mi madre
busco una manera de mejorar las
condiciones de vida de mis congéneres de
mis amigos a mis vecinos veía muchísimo
sufrimiento a mi alrededor y eso me
afectaba muchísimo quería buscar un
camino una salida
y la encontré en la filosofía de la
revolución humana como le repito a los
19 años conozco esta filosofía que
consiste en lo siguiente
transformar por completo al individuo
es una revolución que aunque la palabra
revolución nos lleve a pensar que es
algo bélico grandioso gigantesco que
escapa de lo que yo puedo hacer como
persona común
a veces eso es el mismo pensamiento qué
puedo hacer yo como persona común si soy
insignificante si no soy nada si nadie
me escucha ni sé hablar entonces a dónde
puedo yo mover al mundo muchísimo menos
a dónde puedo mover mi vida
la filosofía de la revolución humana
consiste en cambiar sus creencias y sus
paradigmas que nos ponen en una posición
privada de poder y privado de
inspiración
alguien reconoce a esta persona
cómo se llama
gambi todos vamos conocidos ya sea por
películas
en historias de la televisión en el
libro de texto de historia
si saben que hizo el mahatma gandhi
lideró personalmente una revolución no
violenta en la india para derrocar el
poder y la hegemonía que tenía y el
imperio británico
sin disparar una sola bala y con el
ejemplo de su propia vida libero una
nación entera y logró inspirar a
millones
alguien sabe quién es el martin luther
king acaban de decir si el doctor martin
luther king
para los que no lo conozcan martin
luther king era un pastor
que se dedicó a luchar más allá de lo
que a él le correspondía se dedicó a
luchar por los derechos de los
afroamericanos en eeuu cuando estaban
sufriendo las mayores de los rechazos y
los mayores de las agregaciones y por
último quisiera también presentarles a
nelson mandela
nelson mandela para los que también no
lo pueden no lo llegan a conocer no
saben
qué fue lo que hizo él también liberó
del yugo del apartheid a todo sudáfrica
con su ejemplo y de manera no violenta
entonces estos son claros ejemplos de
revoluciones humanas en la escala macro
o sea que llegaron a afectar a todo el
globo y la historia humana
podemos pensar que también estamos fuera
de ese grupo selecto y pequeño de
personas pero no es así
la revolución humana
para una madre que enfrenta
tener que criar a sus hijos tener que
sacar adelante una familia a veces el
apoyo de un padre la revolución humana
para esa persona es hacerlo de la manera
más alegre y más comprometida posible a
lo mejor para un niño la revolución
humana consiste en decidir ok ya que 5
esta vez en mi clase pero mañana me voy
a esforzar el triple y voy a sacar 10
la revolución humana se puede ver en las
cosas más pequeñas y de hecho comienza
en las cosas más pequeñas de nuestra
vida los pequeños detalles que hacemos
cotidianamente esas cosas que
enfrentamos todos los días es lo que nos
puede llevar a fortalecer oa decidirnos
a llevar a cabo nuestra revolución
humana se basa completamente en una fe
en uno mismo en una convicción
en que uno tiene el potencial ilimitado
del universo dentro de su propia vida
ese potencial creador y ese energía
infinita de la que hablaba en el pasado
o nikola tesla existe en el universo y
existe dentro de sus propios cuerpos
humanos dentro de su propia mente y
dentro de su propia vida
pero
el hecho de desconocer esto o de pensar
que uno no posee ese poder nos hace caer
en esas trampas y caer en ese en esa
falta de poder y lo que la revolución
humana busca es que uno se levante se
empodere y rompe el cascarón del ego
rompe el cascarón de mi vida personal
mis pequeños problemas y vaya al
encuentro de nuestras personas que se
vayan creando puentes de confianza entre
las personas en estos esfuerzos desde de
decidir dedicarnos al bien de decidir
levantarnos como individuos ya sea la
revolución humana un movimiento que
podría liberar no nada más a la ciudad
de los mochis no nada más al país de
méxico que está pasando por una
transición de la cual todos debemos
asumir responsabilidad
la clave está en la educación
y en el objetivo de la educación
estamos educando para qué
la gente ya está harto de la competencia
ya está harta de los pleitos está harta
de la guerra y queremos vivir en paz y
con sensatez
entonces debemos de empezar a educar a
los niños educar a las personas hacia la
paz una distinta forma de ver la vida
una distinta forma de percibir las cosas
ya sé detrás de la filosofía de la
revolución humana
en lo personal
como lo viví como llegó a querer
dedicarme al bien ajeno
desde que conozco esta filosofía la
revolución humana pues me integración
compartirse a los demás y todas salgo de
mi cuarto salgo de mi casa y comienzo
encontrarme con diversas personas que
pensaban totalmente distinto a como yo
pensaba
obviamente
no me era agradable tener que estar
confrontando a cada rato a estas
personas que pensaban tan distinto de
ami que tienen otras opiniones que eran
vaya individuos
y en ese reconocimiento del valor de sus
ideas del valor de su persona y del
valor de la vida ajena es en donde fui
creciendo en este amor por los demás
yo estudié psicología
y en la carrera de psicología no
encontraba la forma de aterrizar esto
que yo estoy hablando cómo puedo hacer
para transformar desde mi individualidad
desde lo que yo tengo bajo control la
sociedad y el mundo
no tuve problemas hasta que decidí dejar
la psicología y dedicaron a la música en
este momento empezaron todos los
problemas
fue gracias a la nutrición de esta
filosofía de la revolución humana que yo
decidí tomar como reto personal tener
éxito a lo que iba a hacer y que de eso
dependía que mis amigos también se
inspirarán a alcanzar sus sueños
porque tenemos el potencial de lograr lo
que se nos venga en mente pero lo que no
tenemos a veces es un aliado que
constantemente nos saliente y
constantemente nos recuerde que tenemos
el poder de levantarnos solos
decidí unirme a mis amigos
en un año
intención de poder llevar la educación y
el arte a todas las personas y surge a
ayudarte un movimiento que integra
artistas pintores músicos literatos y
que él busca llevar una de rocha hacia
las comunidades más necesitadas
aquí podemos ver como una acción pequeña
puede inspirar a 2 a 3 y que una puede
ser madre de 10.000
la verdad ha sido gratificante en gran
medida vivir una vida dedicada al bien
vivir una vida dedicada a los demás
hemos viajado por comunidades hemos
viajado por el campo hemos viajado a los
barrios hemos viajado a muchos lugares
llevando este mensaje de esperanza a
todos tú como persona tú como ser humano
tienes un valor si no pregúntenles a sus
madres
con qué facilidad y más en este estado
en el que vivimos estamos nos
encontramos en sinaloa
se quita la vida se mata con qué
facilidad
no más algo así y se acaba
es importante que nos replanteamos
el valor de la vida es importante como
ciudadanos nos replanteamos la
influencia del poder que tenemos como
personas gracias a esta filosofía y a
mis amigos he podido crear no solamente
ayudarte sino también la productora
black rooster que se ha dedicado a hacer
caldo de cultivo para los proyectos
musicales y para los artistas musicales
aquí en la ciudad
como pueden ver en las diapositivas
nosotros estamos muy muy muy metidos en
la cuestión de las artes de la música
y de la cultura
muchas veces se pudieron haber
preguntado a ustedes bueno aquí voy a
dedicar mi vida que voy a hacer con mis
días que voy a hacer con mis horas
y puede que no haya encontrado una
respuesta aún
de tomar la decisión
de salir de lo que siempre hemos estado
haciendo constantemente puede ser un
paso para llevar a cabo nuestra
revolución humana si se encuentran
estudiando veo que aquí son muchos los
jóvenes que se encuentran la mayoría de
ustedes están en edad escolar supongo yo
está en la escuela y a veces se han de
preguntar a ustedes mismos qué va a
pasar de mi vida como la voy a construir
hacia dónde la voy a llevar
esta filosofía que la van a compartir a
mí me llevó a los escenarios a mí me
llevó a romper el miedo que sentía de
declararle a mi familia que realmente mi
pasión se encontraba en la música y no
entro en una oficina
de no haber tomado la decisión de
dedicarme a lo que realmente amaba
sería una persona sumamente infeliz en
este momento
pero fue gracias al valor
que surgió de mí por la confianza y por
la convicción de que yo tenía la
capacidad de poder llevar a cabo mis
sueños fue que me moví y avance y fui
que venció mi convicción a mis miedos
así que la revolución humana se puede
entender con una lucha y una
conflagración interna entre el impulso
de destrucción y el impulso creativo que
surgen en nosotros y que ahí se
encuentran inherentes a nuestra propia
vida
cual vamos a decidir potencializar ahí
radica la diferencia la felicidad está
muy ligada a esto que les acabo de decir
si no es que son los cimientos totales
de la felicidad personal el valor de
emprender la acción cuando se debe de
emprender la acción
ahora me encuentro en un proceso en el
cual
estoy justamente en donde quería estar
justamente haciendo lo que quería hacer
derrocha felicidad no sé si siente mi
felicidad
no sé no sé si la sientan ojalá que mi
voz pueda transmitirles la felicidad que
me da haber podido vencer en cada
batalla porque cada una de esas
situaciones en las que me metí por
decidir dedicarme a la música fueron
horrendas no se los quiero ni siquiera
platicar aquí pero está firme convicción
en que yo poseía al igual que todos
ustedes lo poseen el poder de atravesar
y de transformar estas circunstancias
desfavorables para mí
esa convicción fue la que me hizo
moverme y lograr lo que realmente deseo
como nos podría ayudar a nosotros como
comunidad la filosofía de la revolución
humana
tú eres bar de diversas maneras pero la
principal
manera en la que nos puede ayudar a esta
filosofía
es el establecer la red de amistad la
red de confianza que se requiere para
poder llevar a cabo movimientos grandes
y para poder llevar a cabo movimientos
efectivos y victoriosos los movimientos
que fracasan son porque dentro de sus
filas hubo una gran desunión y hubo un
gran mal que se filtró y que destruyó
por completo el anhelo y el deseo de los
jóvenes de poder lograr algo
la filosofía de la revolución humana
busca romper esas limitaciones y busca
crear como lo mencioné puentes entre
cada uno de nuestros corazones y
entendimiento para poder llevar a cabo
los sueños de cada uno de ustedes a la
par en la que todos vamos cumpliendo
nuestros sueños es importante que
entendamos que para que exista paz y
para que se eleve la condición de vida
de nuestra comunidad tenemos que
trabajar cada uno dentro de nosotros
mismos
no podemos dejarle la tarea al vecino
ni a los políticos ni a los empresarios
es algo que como personas comunes y
corrientes en mi caso más corriente que
común
podemos lograrlo yo sé que si jamás se
desalienten por pensar que no tienen
dinero y que por eso no valen que no
tienen buena ropa y que por eso no valen
jamás pongan el valor de su vida en los
objetos materiales su vida posee un
valor incalculable de por sí inherente
si no les vuelvo a repetir pregunten a
sus madres
es importante también poseer buenos
mentores para poder llevar a cabo esta
revolución interna cómo voy a
revolucionar mi mundo interior
si no poseo conocimiento o si no poseo
una guía de alguien que ya haya llevado
a cabo un movimiento exitoso yo asumo
como mentor personal al doctor
bueno aquí vemos una foto de él siendo
joven antes de llevar a cabo su lucha
personal y su propia revolución humana
la cual me inspiró desde japón hasta
mexico me inspiro por completo a yo
también llevará a cabo una epopeya
personal casi vamos a llamarle una
epopeya personal
hacia la victoria ya sea la felicidad
sin dejar de lado la victoria y la
felicidad de mis semejantes porque a fin
de cuentas nuestras vidas están
profundamente interrelacionadas
por eso la revolución humana busca que
todos seamos felices que todos
alcancemos nuestra meta y nuestros
sueños al mismo tiempo que nos
convertimos en ciudadanos ejemplares en
hijos ejemplares
en amigos ejemplares en padres
ejemplares y en todos los roles y
papeles que nos lleve
nuestra vida en la sociedad a cubrir o
hacer es importante muy importante que
asumamos nuestro valor y que nos
dediquemos al bien desde lo que nosotros
podemos hacer en nuestros propios nichos
ya sea en la educación en la economía en
la política en la industria hay
muchísimos campos de acción en los
cuales los seres humanos se pueden
dedicar y con los cuales se puede
revolucionar
hablan de cambiar el sistema desde
adentro muchas veces se habla de cambiar
el sistema desde adentro
pero en un sistema externo
qué les parece si cambiamos el sistema
de nuestra vida desde adentro
y eso si logramos vencer el mal si
logramos vencer la ignorancia si
logramos vencer el egoísmo
si logramos vencer la avaricia
podremos estar vislumbrando un futuro
brillante y una paz duradera
la revolución humana en un solo
individuo una profunda transformación
dentro de la vida de un solo individuo
puede transformar el destino no solo de
su ciudad sino de la humanidad completa
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]